yeah you know that tweet you put out the
other day about you know women losing
you know looks from 23
onwards yeah yeah yeah a lot of people
misconstrue that it doesn't mean women
get ugly after 23 yeah you know it does
not mean like that oh she's busted up
and she's washed up at 25 it just means
that you know that's that's when they're
they're probably most attractive and to
be honest like I think people's
preferences change as well as they get
as they get older I mean I I I don't
find I don't find girls in their in
their 20s attractive to be
honest you're ashamed to show up with
a
huh in Translation you're you're ashamed
to show up with a girl in her 20s no
just I like something that b seasoned
and you know something from a jack
veterano painting look up Jack veterano
paintings dras you'll get my drift yeah
50 50 like something with some miles on
it you know he doesn't like to get a new
car he wants to get a get a used car
with a few miles on it you know what I'm
saying well no but the thing is what do
you have in common with a 23 year old if
you're in your or 50s yeah not much if
we're being honest yeah but Rich put out
that tweet and you know a lot of people
jumped on him thinking that he meant
anyone after 23 is is is busted and ugly
you know well that's well that's usually
how it's taken and like the point of the
Tweet really was to clarify that they
hit the wall once which they never see
and then the second time they hit it is
when they have to come to the acceptance
and understanding and realization that
it exists and that are not as
competitive as their younger selves or
as competitive with younger women um to
sort of explain this a little bit more
and moff and I would be dealing with
this on a ladies night on Wednesday um I
did a uh I'm running a poll right now on
the community tab of the uh channel so
you you can go over to the community tab
of the YouTube channel and see what I
posted about there there's her thread
responding to it so this gal her name is
uh Martha Bueno or we I don't know
Martha um and she basically responded by
linking to the tweet and saying you know
rich is a beta and I'm gonna I'm GNA
argue with with his beta Behavior about
uh about this uh notion on Wednesday and
ladies night and I don't I don't argue
with people if you guys who watch my
shows you know I just speak facts and
get into the conversation and most of
the time you know there's either an
agreement or disagreement but she posted
a couple of pictures online one of
herself younger and one of herself today
on her on her profile so I just took
those two pictures and I'm running a
poll to see what you guys think as far
as you know which version of Martha is
more attractive the you know the older
version with four kids or the younger
version that she posted and so far it
looks like most people are uh trending
on the younger version so if you guys
want to take that poll it's on the
community tab it' be awesome to uh get
your feedback on
that but that's what that was all about
just uh yeah I don't know man like it's
I don't know why people try to argue
biology or like stuff that everybody
knows obviously the younger like
19yearold
you is most likely more attractive than
35y old you or 45y old you like it's
it's just not even a I don't know why
people argue about this yeah and I'll
admit like I was better looking too when
I was younger obviously I had more hair
my head I disagree guys
I I could show you guys pictures of me
10 15 years ago and they looked like a
pudgy dark yeah if you're fat I mean if
you're
completely I just you know you know if
you get if you don't have any SW Swagger
you don't become that attractive a lot
of men go through the whole like a lot
of guys will just blow themselves up
like me and my LTR were out a couple of
weeks ago at a you know we had a nice
cocktail by our restaurant and we saw
three guys who were the only reason any
of the ladies were with them is cuz they
were Ballers and they were all gross
mostly out of shape and we were just we
were just laughing at the whole thing
but yeah money is a big equalizer for
men as they get older for sure but
you've said it in the past we age like
wine they age like milk so yeah but I
mean they don't want to hear that
because because I mean what that does is
it is it ties their worth into their
beauty and you know I've said it many
times women are Beauty objects to men
and men are success objects to women but
they they fail to recognize we don't
really care about their degrees we don't
care about the wealth that they've
accumulated mostly because women don't
share their poal with men so they have
other Notions of of value which they
don't seem to understand it'll be a very
similar conversation you know with some
with some slight you know curtails but I
think that it's going to go just about
as I'm you know predicting it right now
and it's like you know an older woman in
her 40s with four kids is not as
attractive as a younger woman with no
kids it's just flat out truth right
freeze those eggs yeah yeah did you do
you think there's any you know
validation to the point of that because
of Western plugged in society has
convinced women to behave like men you
know to binge to be to be to be loud to
be obnoxious and we did say like that
Mara Bueno girl is she's in Miami and a
couple of times have been in Miami like
Latin culture is very very it celebrates
feminine beauty an awful lot and and
they encourage it whereas a lot of you
know Western culture is yeah go out and
drink gallons of white claw and wine and
nothing will happen to you but yeah
somebody will wake up on the wall will
smash the B Jesus out here
mhm yeah well you know the delusion is
real really I mean what else
are very few exceptions to this rule
I've met one or two where they look
better 31 32 than they did when they
were 20 something maybe 25 yeah if
they're out of shape if they're
overweight if they're out of shape if
they don't have any style you
know yeah exactly it's it's possible to
invert that uh bell curve but at the end
of the day
on yeah like you're fighting against
gravity and time and you're just not
going to win well it's not just about
the act the sheer Act of getting older
and physically it's also the trauma you
go through and pick up in your 20s and
early potentially the baggage you
accumulate that makes you a nightmare
for men so I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out